shooters are in a weird place right now
with some of the biggest names in the
industry barely treading water
battlefield 2042 and call of duty
vanguard are kind of meh halo was primed
to come out on top but ran into some
battle pass xp issues with a lack of
live service content ahead of season 2.
so where does that leave you not to
worry because there are still a bunch of
really good games out there if you're
looking for something different so here
are some of the best shooters you can
play right now that aren't call of duty
battlefield or halo
some of you might be surprised to see
this on the list but split gate is a
game that rose from relative obscurity
to absolute hype fest last summer and
for good reason the game was a
shockingly excellent fusion of two game
styles that don't seem like they would
go together the grounded combat and
arenas of halo and the spatial
dimension-defying portals of
well portal the game's population is
down from the peak of last year so
matchmaking might not be as robust as it
was and you might find some folks
claiming the game is officially dead but
that doesn't take away from what is an
incredible shooter and with crossplay
support the free to play game will
surely give you a lot of fun nights
playing it alongside your friends
splitgate is in that rare position where
it sets out to do one thing and does it
exceedingly well in this case the halo
elements of split gate are familiar and
any halo veteran will instantly feel at
home with the different game modes such
as team deathmatch or even oddball the
portals also don't overstay their
welcome as you can't just spam them on
any surface but on strategically placed
portal approved walls in each arena that
are clearly distinguishable from other
surfaces the halo style combat feels
solid with the wide range of guns that
handle similarly to their halo
counterparts but a jet pack and sprint
adds a modern kick to the core gameplay
nailing some wicked snipes or hearing
the papa split gates battle rifle is
definitely satisfying but it's the
portals that add an extra layer to the
core combat loop being able to place a
portal to get a different angle at an
enemy while behind cover or getting an
immediate flank not only feels awesome
but not gonna lie feels like you just
busted out a 9000 iq play too trust me
this game is underrated free to play and
a lot of fun plain and simple
if you're a halo fan and need something
else to play after completing that
battle pass destiny 2 is absolutely a
must to be completely honest destiny 2
is a great game for anyone to play but
there might be a lot of confusion if
you're completely new thankfully there's
a lot of helpful resources online and a
community eager to welcome new players
including at gamespot check out our so
you want to play destiny 2 video for an
awesome look into all the important
things you need to know if you decide to
take the plunge you'll be rewarded with
one of the best live service shooter
games to ever exist seriously outriders
the division anthem even borderlands 3
were all once touted as quote destiny
killers and despite many of them being
decent none have been able to replicate
or topple destiny off its throne destiny
2 currently is on a seasonal model so
you can hop in for a seasonal story
complete with exotic quests and
activities like this season's psyops
battlegrounds playlist there's also a
battle pass with high level armor sets
transmog ornaments exotic engrams and
plenty of currency and materials
alongside some fun cosmetic stuff like
exclusive finishers the game has
countless number of activities such as
strikes dungeons exotic quests raids and
so much more there's a gobstopping
amount of content in lore thanks to the
loot chase and endless challenges and
triumphs to achieve in the game as well
as some of the best world building ever
it was the perfect game during lockdown
and remains the perfect game for folks
who want a comfortable gaming routine
with superb core gun play if you're
someone who wasn't sold on call of duty
vanguard's campaign the witch queen has
an excellent and challenging campaign to
offer with our reviewer phil hornshaw
even considering it to be the best
destiny 2 campaign so far oh but you
want multiplayer no worries hop into the
crucible there's plenty of different
game modes and even an option for
private matches so you can set up
lobbies with your friends and watch all
hell break loose well what if you're a
war zone player well there is no battle
royale in destiny 2 but pvp is free to
play with the exception of the ultimate
hardcore activity trials of osiris which
requires ownership of the most recent
expansion in addition to the standard
game modes of pve or pvp content there
is also interesting hybrid modes like
gambit which gives you a slice of both
worlds in my experience players new to
destiny gravitate to this mode quite a
bit and it can be a lot of fun the game
encourages playing with friends but
there are plenty of options for solo
players to explore as well with full
cross save and cross-play support the
player pool is getting larger by the day
the game is free to play and now is a
perfect time to see what destiny 2 has
to offer
[Music]
escape from tarkov requires a different
type of gamer approach with caution
because this game is not for those
easily frustrated or players that are
used to hand holding in a game not that
it's a bad thing i'm just saying that i
spent about 30 minutes with escape from
tarkov and i wanted to die and then i
did however i had a weird sickening urge
to hop back in maybe i needed to prove
myself maybe i thought this time it
would be different which uh spoiler
alert it wasn't but really what it was
is the realism and difficulty of this
game activated some freaking dark souls
type in my lizard brain tarkov is an
extraction royale which is like a battle
royale but in more of a straight line
where everyone has to make it to exit
points and if you die you lose all of
your gear taken into that round the game
has a ridiculous hard barrier of entry
and keep in mind that the game is
basically in progress and still a beta
build that will run you back 45 bucks so
if you're in it you're in it for the
long haul i hope because the environment
you're trying to survive and extract
from is nothing short of intense the
game requires team communications on
another level what strategy if you want
any chance of making it out alive it
took me several rounds before i found
out how to swap my weapon from auto to
burst fire for example and because
there's no hud you'll need to be
attentive to the subtle cues of
interacting with your loadout as you
explore the area being able to
successfully extract with a healthy pile
of loot to take back to your hideout
feels incredible and the extra risk of
running on your main character instead
of a scab keeps the adrenaline levels at
an all-time high
[Music]
apex legends came out with a vengeance
in the battle royale space and it's hard
to believe that the game has been out
for over 3 years now this is a game
perfect for call of duty fans that are
ok with longer time to kill at launch
the game also refined concepts to
perfection like the ping and respawn
system which was quickly picked up by
its competitors as fans recognized how
useful these mechanics were unlike its
competitors apex required players to go
in teams of three regardless if they
were already in a team or not team
composition matters and most characters
shine when they combine their passive
and active abilities together during
intense firefights or during the final
circles when it's down to just a few
teams left there are other game modes
now such as arenas a super popular mode
that is best compared to something like
counter-strike or valerian you purchase
guns and abilities using credits earned
based on performance with multiple
rounds for a single match and no
respawns totally different feel and it's
perfect for a change of pace from the
classic trio's battle royale over the
years apex has also developed an awesome
story not only in game but through
multimedia each season pushes the
overall story forward and new champions
that are added have rich histories and
relationships with other characters the
story is vast and similar to games like
overwatch or destiny with the huge part
of the world building being done through
both in the game and out you've got
cinematic trailers at the start and
middle of each season character
heirlooms map changes limited time
events and modes voice lines during the
matches a text-driven adventure mode in
the game called quest official tweets
comics and even loading screens the best
part about characters is they let
different types of players make an
impact on the game in a way that feels
rewarding maybe you are super into
shooters but don't really like aggro
attack roles in that case playing a
support role in healing your team or
assisting with recon lets you play an
important role in a way you may prefer
there's something for everyone and that
lets apex stand out from most other
shooters
ah yes chances are your opinion of this
game will vary significantly depending
on how old you are an entire generation
of kids including my little sister
basically grew up on fortnite it's their
generation's golden eye it was literally
everything and everywhere in pop culture
to the point where i can't even tell
which fortnite dances were original if
at all and which were lifted from movie
scenes shows or popular tick tock dances
in 2017 fortnite was so huge i literally
saw someone pretend to drink a chug jug
and wrap themself up with the bandage on
the dance floor at a club yeah it wasn't
the first time either all this to say
that fortnite was at one point in time
the most popular game in the world it
dominated twitch views catapulted
personalities like ninja into stardom
and ushered in a new generation of
gamers completely cracked the [ __ ] out
with building skills so out of this
world you can't imagine how much free
time someone needed to get to this level
trust me i have a lot of history with
this [ __ ] game which makes it really
funny for me to say that you should
absolutely play fortnite and that it is
still a great game forget all the buzz
or past iterations and updates fortnite
has evolved into something
unrecognizable and novel that is worth
revisiting if you played back in the day
you have to go into the comments section
right now and tell me what you think
after you boot it back up again because
i promise you you will not recognize
this game like seriously a few seasons
ago i checked in time just to see ryu
hadouken a banana and i've never been
the same since right now there's a no
build mode which is a must play if
you're a classic fps or third person
shooter type of gamer since it's just
you and your weapons without any pesky
building to get in the way there are
also fun game modes like arena battles
and team elims giving you a variety of
options to play historically though
fortnite has done more than just be a
trendsetter it made iconic events like
summer concerts and huge events from big
stars like ariana grande or marshmallow
and it stands as a model of what a live
service game should look like despite
lifting some of its best ideas from
other games because at its core fortnite
is like a battle royale anthology right
now no build mode is the current best
reason to play especially if you're an
older gamer that doesn't want to mess
around with the building there's an
excellent battle pass that upon
completion guarantees enough v bucks to
buy the next season's battle pass for
free something that other live service
games should definitely take note of and
you can also boot up fortnite and just
like
not even play battle royale if you don't
want like there's other things to do
shockingly enough like taking part and
the pve aspect of the map where you can
fight ai enemies and loot their ship
fortnite is a game worth playing whether
it's for the first time or you fell off
and you want to come back to jump out of
a battle bus for one more round
so we had a chat the other week talking
about some of the aaa shooter games in
the weird state that they were in and
you guys hopped into the comments and
told us some of the games that you're
playing so games you said you were
playing right now from our last shooter
chat was hunt showdown one of you went
back to time splitters doom eternal
indie shooters like proteus and
ultrakill and of course those of you who
never left cs go and rainbow six so keep
those comments coming looking back at
this list maybe it's not so bad that the
usual big hitters like call of duty and
battlefield haven't quite had that same
hype level as years prior because
there's clearly a lot of other shooter
games that are ready to shine so sound
off with what games you're playing
whether it's co-op pvp or campaign
driven and i'll throw them in in our
part 2 video until next time
[Applause]
you